good day las vegas
all right 4 16 on your wednesday morning
the
nominations for the 63rd grammy awards
are in
24 time grammy winner beyonce leads the
pack she got nine nominations including
record of the year
uh taylor swift dualipa each with six
nominations
how about megan the stallion with
several nominations she is favored to
take the title of
best new artist and hey now bts making
history as the first
k-pop band to be nominated you can see
all the grammy awards on january
31st right here on channel 8 and it was
announced that the daily show's trevor
noah
will be the host so how about that john
sherry and alex
wait a second nate how did the killers
do
oh did you see the tweet that the
killers put out it was really funny they
used
all caps going he was rigged we were
robbed
they didn't allow the counting procedure
i i obviously was kind of a joke
yeah you wanted a recount you're gonna
sue
yeah i saw i saw nate retweet that but
uh yeah alex a lot of uh
nifty bands and artists there none of
which i listened to but i should maybe
one day look into that
we do subject john to those artists
taylor swift
yes yes nate tannenbaum she actually
dropped a different version of her album
folklore overnight so
if you haven't listened to that that's
something that she won a lot of awards
for already this year so
all right shall we talk about the
weather you guys quickly i know we don't
have a hold on
i just real quickly want to mention that
my friend john prine
my all-time favorite singer who died of
covet earlier this year has two grammy
nominations for best american roots
song and best american roots performance
so
kudos to the prine family oh congrats to
him